when it comes to filling a more
traditional badass role in the hero list
of overwatch McCree is one of those
number-one dudes the gunslinger from the
Wild West Chris waters here folks with
Mike McCarty here to talk you through
the basics of this gunslinger and how to
do the damage with his big Magnum the
Peacekeeper mike yeah this thing's
awesome not only because it can be
really powerful but it's also pretty
accurate if your scale with him he's a
skilled character or you have to be
skilled to play him at least and you can
fan the hammer up close you can shoot it
from far away obviously have six shots
there's a way to you know to reload it
instantly with the dodge roll he's a
really dirty character overall which is
why I really like him he can function
solo on his own and the Peacekeeper is
kind of the catalyst for all of that he
does some dirty stuff on the flank for
sure but let's start with the basics the
Peacekeeper has two fire modes you can
fire single shots up to six or you could
fan the hammer and just unload all the
bullets that are left in your clip in
one go if the single shot is really
solid for doing damage on the main
objective you know you're you're you're
picking off heroes you're hassling
supports at you know mid-range and yet
you do need to land your shots so if
you're not super confident landing those
shots you know you're gonna want to ease
into McCree but I the fan the hammer is
where things start getting really dirty
that's him unloading real quick when's
the best time to use that mic it's
really good against anyone really it's
harder to control but it's awesome for
taking out tank you can go into a room
and just fan the hammer if you land all
six shots you can take out road hog you
take out Reinhardt you can take out
divas mech it's really powerful it's
also kind of overpowered if you know how
to use it really well if you can do one
and then his dodge roll the combat roll
ability instantly reloads it so you can
fan the hammer all six shots kill it you
know best case scenario killer road hog
dodge roll automatically there's no
reload animation the guns just ready to
go fan the hammer six more times kill
any other character and especially with
tanks they're easy to hit with all those
six shots right but you do have to be
pretty close for those shots to all land
on the character and so when you're in
close McCree is not actually a very fast
character and so you rely on one big key
ability to help arrest the mobility of
others and that's the flashbang the
flashbang is awesome it's my favorite
part because it's such a great counter
to almost anyone like the bigger
characters you don't need as much but if
you're going against a Reaper or tracer
or
even her pilot form traditionally
elusive characters it's great it stuns
them Fanta hammers gonna kill anybody in
that state it's also a great chance to
get away if you need to if you're kind
of too close to reaper for comfort it's
a great escape mechanism as well yeah
the flashbang and fan the hammer combo
is where the Kree goes to town so be
very comfortable with that the combat
role for the quick reload then you can
fan the hammer right again if you need
to if you missed some of your shots or
if you're taking on a tank and you need
a little extra help important to keep in
mind that McCree also doesn't have a ton
of health so one Widowmaker shot and
you're going to be in trouble so you
even though you can heckle her at range
that's really not a fight you want to
pick you want to stay on those flanks
McCree does best when he's one-on-one
and that's where you want to do your
business now let's talk about his
ultimate Deadeye Deadeye is tough to
master but if you know how to use it it
is deadly so how do you use it so it's
best to activate it kind of when you're
in cover so you cuz he walks even slower
than his normal really slow pace and you
can come around a corner and you let
take about two seconds to zero in on
anybody in your sight and then even when
they go behind cover you'll still have
the target on them but when you decide
to pull the trigger is pretty crucial
because you want to make sure all these
red skulls are seeing which indicate
you're about to kill them no matter what
character with one shot you want to make
sure they're not behind cover so you can
maximize how many people you kill the
reason you do it from behind cover is
because whenever you activate it McCree
goes it's high noon and everyone on the
map starts looking around trying to find
McCree and also you start glowing a
little bit orange so you are easy to
spot so that's why if you're out of the
easy visual range and then you kind of
saunter around the corner that's a good
way to sort of avoid getting yourself
shot
because macri's ultimate is very
interrupted so if you're a Widowmaker a
Hanzo
you know any kind of precision shot
getting close try to take out that
McCree if you're a Winston if you're May
if you're Reinhard get up your shield
get up your ice wall those are counters
to macri's ultimate because this is
potentially the most powerful ultimate
in the game but yeah you trade a lot of
damage for even more vulnerability than
he usually has alright thanks Mike that
is McCree for you folks deadly on the
flanks in one-on-one with those
flashbang fan the hammer engagements and
also a pretty dirty dude down the main
Lane with his ultimate and with his mid
range peacekeeping abilities for more
/ watch tips be sure to subscribe to
GameSpot and come on back we'll have a
whole roster for you here soon enough